[Música]
el sentimiento general es de
incertidumbre sobre el futuro de la
economía mundial
múltiples son los factores veamos
algunos de ellos solamente para
mencionarles los principales por ejemplo
la inflación las altas tasas de interés
el impacto de la guerra en ucrania en el
mundo también el aumento en los precios
de la energía las fluctuaciones que ha
tenido el precio del petróleo a nivel
mundial a esto hay que sumarle también
los diferentes desafíos que está
afrontando la sociedad por ejemplo
vencer la polarización que es algo que
está sucediendo en varios países al
mismo tiempo la crisis de credibilidad
que hay en términos democráticos la
pandemia del joven 19 que sigue activa
todavía no hemos terminado la pandemia
no la hemos dejado de lado no ha
terminado esa crisis también la crisis
medioambiental y el cambio climático por
supuesto que sigue haciendo estragos en
diferentes partes del mundo lo vemos por
ejemplo como los incendios forestales
que se están presentando en california
en portugal en españa en diferentes
partes del mundo y también las extremas
olas de calor que se están viviendo en
este verano
las intensas nevadas que se ven en otras
partes del planeta por ejemplo en
argentina y en chile debido al invierno
austral según los expertos la
incertidumbre y la especulación son tal
vez los factores que dominan el
escenario mundial en este momento y eso
lleva a varios cuestionamientos por
ejemplo entrar a eeuu si o no en una
recesión después del verano qué pasará
con alemania que es el motor económico
de europa y de la zona euro si deja de
recibir el suministro de gas y de
petróleo de rusia cuál será el impacto
que tendrán estos dos factores en
américa latina en donde ya hay una alta
inflación y una depreciación de las
monedas locales qué pasará con los
mercados emergentes y en países en donde
hay o recientemente hubo elecciones o
hay en procesos que generan
incertidumbre a nivel político que
puedan tener
diferentes desenlaces y que algún
impacto en la economía como por ejemplo
en colombia en donde un nuevo gobierno
va a asumir en las próximas semanas
también en chile en donde puede ser
estable una nueva constitución no en
brasil en donde hay elecciones en unos
meses por eso hoy en el debate de france
24 preguntamos recesión mundial
inevitable para eso hemos invitado a
gabriela calderón ella es investigadora
del instituto cato ella es máster en
comercio y política internacional y se
encuentra en la ciudad de guayaquil en
ecuador desde monterrey en nuevo león
méxico se conecta el doctor eduardo
carvajal eres profesor investigador de
finanzas y economía del tecnológico de
monterrey les recuerdo que ustedes
también hacen parte de esta conversación
pueden dejar todos sus comentarios y sus
preguntas en nuestras redes sociales
estamos en twitter en instagram y en
facebook en donde nos encuentran como
france24
santi logo que es mi cuenta personal la
etiqueta es numeral el debate efe 24
para que dejen todos sus comentarios
también les recuerdo que en youtube
pueden seguir nuestra señal en streaming
y aprovecho para saludar a las personas
que nos escuchan en nuestro podcast los
invito para que escuchen todos los
contenidos de nuestro programa que ya
están en diferentes plataformas ya usted
las venden a paul podcast en spotify
deezer y en ti
pues bien no siento más extra el
contexto doy paso entonces al análisis
con mis invitados comienzo con gabriel a
la ciudad de guayaquil primero saludando
la agradeciéndole que esté con nosotros
en el programa y el punto de partida
para la discusión la pregunta que se
hacen todos los analistas y los
ciudadanos del común en este momento se
la trasladó a usted gabriela estamos o
no al borde de una recesión y es
evitable o no
bueno todo parece indicar cada vez más
que estaríamos al inicio de una recesión
producto de básicamente las políticas de
los principales bancos centrales la
reserva federal y luego el banco central
de europa que ha sido mucho más digamos
laxo que la reserva federal en su
política monetaria y esto sería estaría
indicado por la incapacidad de
reaccionar a tiempo por parte de las
autoridades de la reserva federal frente
a lo que era evidentemente un exceso en
la creación de dinero que se dio a raíz
de la pandemia es decir en año y medio
la oferta monetaria según la medida m2
que es la medida más amplia dinero
creció en 41% en eeuu mientras hubo un
crecimiento anual promedio de 16 por
ciento eso eso vaticinaba que iba a
haber una inflación y luego para
controlarla si se lo hace muy tarde hay
que poder subir demasiado las tasas de
interés y eso pues induciría una
recesión
la misma pregunta para el doctor para
bajar en la ciudad de monterrey está
usted de acuerdo estamos o no al borde
de una recesión como lo vio usted y si
ésta es evitable estamos transitando por
el borde del abismo pero puede que no
nos caigamos doctores
nos recuerda la buenas tardes antes que
nada recuerda la teoría de los ciclos
económicos
es correcto que estemos cerca de una
recesión mundial y es
probable que la actuación de los bancos
centrales tanto el golpe o comunidad
esté en mi colega y la actuación de la
reserva federal de eeuu sea un poco
tardía por lo tanto es altamente
probable que estemos al borde de una
recesión mundial
doctor que al bajar continuó con usted
para hacer la ronda a la inversa para el
ciudadano al común para los habitantes
en américa latina' yo ya les mencionaba
algunos de los factores que estamos
viendo que pueden ser esos ingredientes
para llegar a esa recesión que puede
estar comenzando a finales del verano
boreal es decir más o menos para el mes
de septiembre pero desde su punto de
vista cuál es ese factor puntual que
detonó todo esto fue la pandemia del cob
y 19 fue el confinamiento en el que nos
vimos forzados la gran mayoría de países
alrededor del mundo o cuál es su punto
de vista
bueno mi opinión muy particular es de
que es un efecto multifactorial el
asunto es de qué
había unas condiciones de crecimiento
bastante difíciles antes de la pandemia
y la pandemia solamente vino a
prolongar o hacer un poco más aguda la
crisis en este sentido pues las medidas
que se adoptaban para apoyar tanto a las
personas como a las empresas pues es una
medida netamente inflacionaria soltar
recursos este hasta los
la cantidad de dinero que estaba
disponible para los ciudadanos en eeuu y
en europa era demasiado y eso pues en un
momento dado pues se va a reflejar en
las altas tasas de inflación que tenemos
en este sentido pues yo creo que es
parte de la
medicina que se tenía que tomar para
apoyar a las empresas durante la
pandemia pero es evidente que pues no sé
y vivieron bien los efectos y es ahora
que las políticas contracíclicas dicen
vamos a tener que hacer una política
donde recontra activa y aunque aumentar
las tasas eso hace más salud de la
recesión sino que simplemente presiona
el crédito se hace cada vez más caro
gabriela tomando en cuenta lo que
explica el doctor carvajal
se sabía que esta receta para dar
solución o por lo menos un poco de
alivio durante los meses más crudos de
la pandemia de kobe 19 eran medidas que
fomentaban el aumento de la inflación en
las diferentes economías sabiendo esto
había forma de prevenir un poco y frenar
ese incremento de la inflación como se
está viendo en países de américa latina
o era simplemente el curso que toca
dejarle dar a la economía para poder que
se estabilice más adelante
bueno hay unos artículos interesantes
publicados por los economistas greenwood
y stephen kim de la johns hopkins
university y en el wall street journal
que se han publicado desde el año pasado
donde ellos venían señalando que esto se
veía venir en base a un indicador que ha
sido frecuentemente ignorado por las
autoridades de la reserva federal de los
eeuu y esto es el crecimiento de la
oferta monetaria en su expresión más
amplia que es la mención m2 y digamos si
esto estaba muy por encima de lo que la
actividad económica real representaba
pues esto iba a resultar en una clásica
situación de demasiado dinero
persiguiendo demasiados pocos bienes y
eso es lo que termina derivando en una
presión inflacionaria y por otra parte
luego tenemos que como ya hay estas
expectativas inflacionarias frente a la
política sostenida durante un largo
tiempo ahora va a ser más difícil
controlar la inflación probablemente van
a tener que subir más los tipos de
interés y por eso probablemente también
la inflación ahora dure más quizás ellos
estiman estos economistas estiman de
a 24 meses adicionales eso es muy
importante sobre todo para países de
américa latina que están sumamente
endeudado 12 a 24 meses gabriela pero
hay un hay un tema importante para
analizar y es que la pandemia de kobe 19
no ha terminado y estamos todavía ante
la aparición de múltiples variantes
y sus variantes que pueden llevarnos a
un escenario similar al del 2020 o al
2021 en cualquier momento si empiezan a
dispararse nuevamente los casos de
contagio y de fallecidos estamos
entonces siendo muy optimistas pensando
que esto en 12 ó 24 meses puede empezar
a
disminuir el índice de la inflación o
simplemente porque la pandemia siga
vamos a seguir presentando estos
indicadores que estamos presentando
pero yo no no pensaba que estaba siendo
optimista me aparece durísimo porque es
una combinación de una recesión con una
inflación eso es lo que se conocía se
conoce como estanflación y realmente es
lo que se buscaba evitar a la ex
gobernadora de la reserva federal y
ellen se disculpó por pensar que era
algo transitorio lo de la inflación el
señor powell que la sucedió dijo el año
pasado que realmente no era importante
el crecimiento del m2 ahora estamos
viendo que ha sido reivindicada la
teoría monetaria de que pues esto si
deriva en inflación y es muy difícil
tener un aterrizaje suave y hay una
digamos es un equilibrio muy difícil de
sostener sin inducir una recesión y
bueno ahora es está dando este ajuste
que sin duda va a ser duro y puede ser
una cuestión que dure de 1 a 2
su opinión doctor trabajar sobre este
tema 12 o 24 meses es lo que estiman
según lo que nos comenta gabriela pero
es que la pandemia todavía continúa y no
sabemos si el virus se va a mitigar un
poco y vamos a aprender a convivir con
él y vamos a tenerlo ya como parte de
nuestra vida normal o si vamos a estar
nuevamente ante confinamiento cierres y
pues parálisis económica de diferentes
países no sabemos qué va a suceder
es seguro que estaremos en un periodo de
estanflación
en ese sentido la duración siempre de
estos periodos de estanflación va a
depender de las variables que lo hacen
mucho más grave o mucho más crónico
en este sentido si la si la
pandemia de kobe
aún no puede lograr una una estabilidad
a la baja en todo el mundo podemos
pensar que puede durar de 12 a 24 meses
el periodo de estancamiento con
inflación
y no solamente es el commit sino también
la guerra en ucrania algunos analistas
internacionales opinaban que iba a durar
poco si la intervención rusa iba a ser
muy efectiva y hemos visto que no y por
lo tanto pues se está extendiendo más de
lo previsto por los analistas
internacionales y creo que esto también
puede llevar a una escasez de bienes y
servicios en europa que hace que se
encarezcan y pues se tomen medidas
bastante drásticas en términos
económicos por lo tanto mi opinión es de
que es altamente probable que dure
entre 1 y 2 años este periodo de
estanflación doctor ya vamos a analizar
también cambie las vamos a analizar el
tema de europa quiero hablar del tema de
eeuu porque es tal vez la economía que
más relación y conexión tiene con
américa latina'
en caso de que eeuu entre en un periodo
de recesión a partir del mes de
septiembre que es cuando finaliza el
verano como puede ser el impacto para
las economías de américa latina lo digo
por países que tienen el dólar como su
moneda tipo el salvador panamá ecuador o
países que dependen altamente de la
economía y de las exportaciones hacia
eeuu como es el caso de méxico doctor
como puede ser esa ola hacia centro y
suramérica
bueno no es desconocido para muchos que
la economía mexicana en particular y
algunas economías tenemos una alta
dependencia de la economía de eeuu cerca
del 80% de los bienes y servicios
producidos y dedicados a la exportación
pues van al mercado norteamericano en
este sentido cualquier
situación económica de estancamiento y
de inflación pues afecta directamente a
las economías dependientes de eeuu en
este sentido pues yo veo un poquito más
de libertad en los países de américa del
sur que tienen un poco más
diversificado su comercio y es evidente
que un súper dólar como lo que estamos
viendo actualmente pues tiene un efecto
en el comercio internacional y eso haría
que las que el comercio se afectara
bastante que las importaciones empezaran
a encarecer y bueno pues es un buen
momento para buscar otras alternativas
económicas no solamente me refiero a
méxico sino economías que dependen
bastante del dólar de eeuu
gabriela y en este panorama que podemos
hacer en la zona de suramérica donde
antes del inicio de la pandemia veíamos
economías seriamente afectadas esto
hablando de argentina que arrastra una
inflación ya de hace muchos de hace
muchos meses y unos problemas económicos
que ya van a superar las tres décadas
venezuela también venía arrastrando
muchísimos problemas y algunas economías
un poco más estables como uruguay chile
que fue golpeada por la pandemia en
cierta forma colombia en cuál es el
panorama que usted ve para américa
latina particularmente para suramérica
si eeuu entra en una recesión
bueno como decía digamos mi colega
evidentemente va a afectar
inmediatamente a los que dependen más en
su comercio con eeuu muchos países en
américa latina ya no tienen como
principal socio comercial a los eeuu
sino quizás a la china pero sin embargo
la dependencia de china y eeuu es mutua
no hay forma de que una recesión en eeuu
no termine afectando a china y por ende
eso también se contagiaría hacia
aquellos que son digamos los principios
tienen a china como su principal socio
comercial es decir esto va a afectar sí
o sí a toda la economía mundial ahora lo
que afecta particularmente a los países
latinoamericanos que están altamente
endeudados es el alza de las tasas de
interés y también frente al alza de los
tipos de interés por parte de la reserva
federal en eeuu hay muchos fondos muchos
capitales que están saliendo de mercados
emergentes en américa latina' y
volviendo
al mercado estadounidense en busca de un
refugio de seguridad frente a la
volatilidad y también porque se vuelve
más atractivo realizar inversiones y
tener dinero en dólares frente a la tasa
de interés más alta entonces esto afecta
por doble partida a latinoamérica y para
los países dolarizados sin embargo no se
da el efecto de empobrecimiento es decir
la volatilidad de las monedas nacionales
como el peso colombiano ni se diga el
peso argentino hace que haya un efecto
de empobrecimiento porque la moneda en
la que los trabajadores de esos países
reciben sus sueldos ahora compra menos
sin embargo con el super dólar como
decía mi colega ahora los el poder
adquisitivo de los ecuatorianos se ve
apreciado y por ende hay un efecto de
sustitución en lugar de un efecto
empobrecimiento es probable que haya una
mayor impuestos que los ecuatorianos
sustituyan su consumo por productos
denominados en otras monedas que se han
vuelto y se han depreciado en relación
al dólar y puede no ver a muchos
ecuatorianos cruzando la frontera hacia
el sur de colombia para comprar algunos
productos precisamente por esos precios
que le sale a favor porque pues colombia
se muestra como mercado muy barato
precisamente para los ecuatorianos
quiero preguntarle y gabriela por un
caso en particular en suramérica no sé
qué tanta información tenga al respecto
pero si hay un país que está logrando
hacer le quite digámoslo así a esta ola
inflacionaria en suramérica es bolivia y
es tal vez el país que venía arrastrando
muchos problemas económicos y políticos
al inicio de la pandemia 19 pero pero
bolivia ahora logra mantener unas cifras
de inflación bastante
controladas y el país prácticamente se
está mostrando como un poco más estable
si se compara con los vecinos
bueno durante todo el gobierno de evo
morales lo sorprendente es que hubo muy
poca intervención con las autoridades de
su banco central ellos han mantenido a
través de distintas administraciones una
política monetaria relativamente
digamos relativamente estable y tienen
una inflación de 3,2 por ciento que por
cierto no es muy distinta a la inflación
de alrededor de 3% que tiene el ecuador
no obstante eso no está determinado en
nuestro caso por la dolarización porque
la inflación de panamá por ejemplo
duplica la nuestra y ellos también están
dolarizados lo que lo que creo que
ocurre en bolivia es que no se ha
intervenido con esa estabilidad de
independencia del banco central y en el
caso del ecuador pues nosotros
continuamos ajustando el tipo de cambio
real que estaba artificialmente
apreciado durante la época de rafael
correa con todas las barreras al
comercio internacional que se han ido
limitando se han ido eliminando perdón
poco a poco
en el caso de bolivia exactamente ahí lo
explica gabriela muy claramente lo que
puede estar sucediendo allí doctor
carvajal pasó a preguntarle por el caso
europeo nos salimos de nuestro
continente y nos vamos a europa también
hay muchísima incertidumbre sobre todo
por una crisis energética que puede
estar a la vuelta de la esquina rusia
anunció que suspende el suministro de
gas a través del norte stream 1 por
espacio de 10 días pero alemania teme
que esto pueda prolongarse y que pueda
quedar cancelado por completo esto en
términos económicos en que se va a
traducir para alemania que es el motor
económico de europa y de la eurozona
bien esto la adquisición de energía a
precios más altos va a ser que
obviamente hay una transferencia hacia
los bienes y servicios que se consumen
en el país no se encarece
por el aumento en los precios de la
energía pero esto no solamente es un
efecto oeste localizado en alemania
alemania tiene reservas bastante grandes
es el país que más utiliza el carbón y
el efecto que va a tener sobre el medio
ambiente va a ser bastante alto verdad
en un compromiso de disminución de
toneladas de dióxido de carbono al año y
me parece que en este año va a tener que
sufrir un poco para poder cumplirlo no
solamente es la parte medioambiental
tampoco en la parte económica sino que
la zona en general se va a ver afectada
porque alemania es el motor de
crecimiento de algunos países
dependientes y esto va a ser que también
se encarezcan los bienes y los servicios
alrededor de las economías que dependen
de alemania es un escenario bastante
negativo en el aspecto de qué
no le vemos solución pronta a la guerra
ni una reanudación de la de el gas o de
la del petróleo ruso hacia europa y creo
que esto sí puede derivarse un
terrible este escenario de aquí a
diciembre pues porque las demandas de
energía durante los meses más fríos pues
son más altas entonces este de mi punto
de vista éste quiera vender a ver una
solución política a la guerra de un gran
y rusia- slim y que restablecer los
flujos de energía y también levantar esa
serie de sanciones económicas y
financieras que han recibido rusia por
parte de la unión europea de eeuu canadá
y otros actores internacionales la misma
pregunta del caso de eeuu pero esta vez
para el caso de europa doctor esto qué
efecto puede tener en la economía
latinoamericana en general en donde pues
el euro ya vemos que pierde terreno
frente al dólar aunque ya lo hemos dicho
el dólar pues es la moneda o la divisa
más usada en américa latina para las
transacciones internacionales es mucho
más que el euro pero el euro sigue
siendo segunda moneda más importante del
mundo a pesar de estar prácticamente en
paridad con él con el dólar
si lo que vimos es un doble efecto
verdad una apreciación del dólar de eeuu
y una depreciación del euro
esto hace que pues el día de hoy a las 4
22 de la mañana pues tuviéramos una
variedad de 111 verdad esto es bastante
este extraño porque no estamos
acostumbrados a tener esta paridad pero
lo interesante es que esto pues
reconfiguró un poquito el tipo de
relaciones que podemos hacer tanto
económicas como comerciales con los
países europeos para efectos relativos
pues en américa latina tenemos ahora
un acceso a precios pues diferenciados
si son el este de europa verdad lo que
nos puede dar la oportunidad de
convertir o modificar un poquito pues en
nuestra estructura de comercio no
depender tanto de eeuu un poco más de
europa y eso se configuraría mucho pues
la solución de los problemas que
enfrenta europa
en el caso de los países que usan el
dólar pues es evidente que mejora su
poder adquisitivo mejora el poder de
compra de los tenedores de dólares y eso
hace pues que
el tenedor de dólares eeuu y los
habitantes eeuu pueden en un momento
dado salir al mundo a comprar bienes y
servicios pues porque tienen una moneda
con bastante poder adquisitivo muy
fuerte en este momento el dólar usted
hablan de nominal del super dólar
gabriela regreso con usted allí en la
ciudad de guayaquil y esta serie de
problemas económicos que se están
presentando en el mundo en diferentes
países también va ligado a una serie de
acontecimientos políticos ya lo
mencionaba yo algunos países en donde
están cercanos a realizar una elección
importante acaso brasil por ejemplo que
está a punto de ir a elecciones al final
del año o chile que se apresta para
hacer una aprobación de una nueva
constitución que podría transformar
completamente la visión de ese país y
colombia que espera la instauración de
un nuevo gobierno de un toque más de
izquierda esta serie de transformaciones
políticas que tanta incertidumbre
generan en la economía uno ve el caso
colombiano en donde todo el tiempo los
medios colombianos le piden al
presidente electo gustavo petro que diga
algo ante los medios de comunicación
para un poco
bajar ese incremento del precio del
dólar en ese país que se puede decir en
esos casos o en esos tres casos en
particular
ya afortunadamente en mi país estamos
dolarizados y las crisis políticas están
divorciadas del tipo de cambio aquí
tuvimos un paro nacional de 18 días y no
hubo ninguna
volatilidad en el mercado cambiario
porque simplemente no existe la política
cambiaria eso es una gran bendición en
medio de todo el caos y en medio de toda
la incertidumbre que es inevitable en un
mundo con pandemia y bueno pues la
guerra en ucrania y la volatilidad que
se deriva en los precios de los
commodities una cosa que si quisiera
aclarar es que si bien el dólar se
aprecia esto no no cambia mucho la
situación para los países
latinoamericanos que son exportadores de
bienes cuyos precios son determinados en
el mercado mundial y están denominados
en dólares es decir esto aquí no no
cambia con el tipo de cambio porque son
precios mundiales y eso no afecta a los
bienes transables es decir aquellos
bienes que cruzan las fronteras pero si
afecta
si hace que se sienta que son mucho más
baratos los bienes no transables es
decir cortarse el pelo en bogotá se
vuelve mucho más barato que cortarse el
pelo en guayaquil para darle un ejemplo
comer en un restaurante en digamos en
miami se vuelve mucho más caro que comer
un restaurante en buenos aires este es
el tipo de fluctuaciones que vamos a ver
por eso se reportaba por ejemplo que
para los turistas americanos se ha
vuelto más atractivo viajar a europa sin
embargo sigue altísimo el costo de los
pasajes porque esto el costo estos
pasajes está denominado en dólares es
importante ese punto y también a la
industria aérea le ha costado un montón
volverse a poner en pie de manera al
100% precisamente por las fluctuaciones
que tiene el petróleo y también porque
algunos de los costes de la operación
aeronáutica está en dólares y eso le
cuesta mucho sobre todas las empresas
latinoamericanas que tienen que pagar
leasing de los aviones en dólares doctor
carvajal le preguntó por el caso de
méxico méxico también está registrando
altos índices de inflación que están
haciendo allí para manejarlas siendo la
segunda economía más importante américa
latina' vale la pena seguirle la pista
de lo que tomen allí en cuanto a
decisiones por parte del gobierno
así es tenemos una inflación oficial de
7.99 por ciento una inflación que es de
las más altas en los últimos 21 años lo
cual nos obliga al banco central a tomar
medidas de política restrictiva eso hace
que los los créditos suban porque sube
la tasa de interés de referencia y eso
pues provoca un encarecimiento para la
inversión privada y en ese sentido pues
es bastante
difícil el panorama dado que tenemos una
incapacidad de crecimiento muy fuerte
porque pues tenemos una baja inversión
está cerca a una recesión en eeuu lo
cual hace el panorama un poquito más un
poquito más más difícil verdad la receta
económica es si hay inflación pues trata
de que tus créditos sean un poco más
altos trata de aumentar la tasa de
interés pero esa receta no funciona
ahorita porque
las expectativas de crecimiento de la
economía mexicana son por debajo de las
expectativas que nos han dado el banco
mundial y el fondo monetario
internacional fue dado a una incapacidad
de inversión tanto pública como privada
pues eso hace que el modelo económico
pues no crees no nos haga crecer
demasiado
yo creo que tiene que suceder
algo extraordinario en la política
económica para que méxico no caiga en
esa vorágine en la que va a querer junto
a eeuu es muy difícil es muy difícil
pensar ahorita en una solución de
botepronto porque este no hay elementos
que te permitan crear un escenario estoy
bastante optimista claro y citó el caso
mexicano no solamente porque la segunda
economía más importante américa latina
sino porque también es considerado como
un mercado emergente junto con brasil e
indonesia con otros países alrededor del
mundo y la lupa está puesta sobre estos
países el comportamiento que van a tener
a nivel económico porque son buenos
potencias o mercados emergentes en
diferentes regiones puntuales del mundo
en donde pues logran tener una especie
de lo que lo que hace méxico se siente
en centroamérica y en cierta forma en
sudamérica entonces por eso vale la pena
analizarlo hago una pregunta que me hizo
nuestro productor del programa nos
preguntaba qué tan seguro era seguir
ahorrando en dólares para la persona ya
del común que logra sacar parte de su
salario para ahorrar en dólares
está costosísimo comprarlo en algunos
países pero esto sigue siendo una buena
reserva para para pensar en el largo
plazo en seguir ahorrando en dólares
seguir ahorrando en esta divisa como lo
ve usted gabriel a
bueno todo depende de las alternativas
reales disponibles y lo que estamos
viendo es que en los momentos de mayor
incertidumbre particularmente allá por
el año 2020 marzo abril y mayo hubo una
fuga hacia la seguridad en inglés es la
frase la famosa frase flight safety era
de todo el mundo a refugiarse en los
bonos del tesoro y se disparó se apreció
el dólar ahora hay otra razón por la que
la gente se digamos recurre o demanda
más dólares y esto es porque se vuelve
más atractivo frente a la suma de los
tipos de interés entonces cada que suben
los tipos de interés esto se vuelve más
atractivo para quienes buscan en qué
moneda ahorrar a la inversa cuando se
mantiene durante largos periodos en
negativo en territorio negativo o en 0
la tasa de interés como continúa siendo
el caso en el banco central de europa lo
que se hace es al revés castigar a las
personas que desean ahorrar en esa
moneda
doctor carvajal pregunta también del
ciudadano a pie del ciudadano
latinoamericano como todavía no hemos
entrado en recesión ya estamos en
dificultades económicas pero un
ciudadano normal como puede prepararse
para para este tipo de de recesiones que
pueden tener impacto en américa latina'
qué medidas podemos tener de cautela en
este par de meses que nos quedan
las recomendaciones típicas son tratar
de evitar créditos a largo plazo con
tasas mayores que la inflación
segundo puedes tener una una cantidad de
ahorros que le permita tener pues al
menos unos tres meses de ingresos en
caso de que haya un despido
otra de las medidas que siempre
recomendamos es tener un fondo de
emergencias que les permita puedes hacer
frente a imponderables
si vemos el escenario es un escenario de
altas tasas de interés
es evidente que si hay una una situación
de desempleo tendrías que enfrentar
créditos hipotecarios o créditos al
consumo que sean con altas tasas y tus
ingresos van a ser en términos reales
los mismos por lo tanto las
recomendaciones trata de ahorrar trata
de no meterte en créditos muy grandes
trata de no esté gastar de manera
onerosa o en bienes superfluos y eso
pues de algún momento dado te prepara un
poco no digo que es la gran solución
pero son medidas que el ciudadano y el
ciudadano de que se preocupa por el
consumo en el día a día podría empezar a
tomar este en preparación para los meses
que pueden venir si un ciudadano que no
veten su salario de lo que gana por su
trabajo gabriela algo que añadir a estas
sugerencias para el ciudadano común para
lo que para que nos preparemos para lo
que puede llegar a suceder todavía no
sabemos si puede pasar pero estamos a
unos meses de acuerdo a los analistas
pero pero alguna indicación para
prepararnos
bueno toda recesión expone errores
cometidos durante época de bonanza y
creo que también es una oportunidad para
aquellos que la recesión los agarre con
ahorros para invertir en aquellas
oportunidades que se vuelvan evidentes
frente a la recesión yo creo que eso
también es es un consejo válido aparte
obviamente no meterse en grandes deudas
si es que no lo han hecho ya digamos
estar alertas a las nuevas oportunidades
de inversión que se van a volver muy
atractivas
en un entorno de recesión
pero me quedan ya pocos minutos para
terminar el programa quiero que hagamos
las conclusiones comienzo entonces con
el doctor trabajar en monterrey las
conclusiones de lo que puede venir ya lo
hemos dicho no tenemos la bola de
cristal no sabemos que lo que va a pasar
en el futuro económico de nuestra región
pero su panorama que es lo que nos viene
para los próximos meses a que nos
tenemos que atener
bueno es cierto no tenemos una bola de
cristal no podemos saber el futuro solo
podemos leer las gráficas leer las
estadísticas leer los números y las
tendencias y tomar una decisión al
respecto yo creo que sí es altamente
probable que tengamos una recesión en el
corto plazo
y que tengamos una situación en la cual
tengamos tasas de inflación altas tasas
de interés altas que nos van a retar en
términos económicos a nivel
macroeconómico pero a nivel
microeconómico lo que nos corresponde en
nosotros hacer es tener prudencia tener
prudencia y tener una capacidad de
abstenerse de hacer compras superfluas
en las intenciones si tú es una tormenta
lo único que puedes hacer es tratar de
resguardar te no puedes luchar contra
ella no puedes evitarla lo único que
puede ser es de qué manera yo me protejo
de tal manera que no me vaya mal que les
late menos hay la recesión y gabriel a
su conclusión para el cierre del
programa
bueno yo concuerdo que creo que va a
haber una recesión
combinada con una inflación y por ende
creo que los gobiernos en américa latina
deberían intentar aliviar en la medida
de lo posible por la vía de una
reducción de impuestos y carga
regulatoria a lo que lo que queda del
tejido empresarial luego de la pandemia
yo creo que es la única
receta de política económica que procede
en este nuevo entorno muy difícil para
cualquier individuo y empresa pues a
gabriela calderón y al doctor eduardo
carvajal les agradezco mucho por haber
estado con nosotros haber hecho este
análisis para la audiencia de france 24
en américa latina' tratamos de manejar
el tema desde las grandes economías de
eeuu europa hasta el bolsillo del
ciudadano común en en américa latina'
esperamos haberles dejado algunos
consejos
importantes para hacer frente a lo que
se nos viene en términos económicos y
sobre todo haberles explicado este tema
que se habla muy técnicamente pero el
ciudadano a pie necesita también
entender qué es lo que está sucediendo
con la economía de la región muchísimas
gracias por este análisis si a ustedes
les agradezco por la sintonía pueden
seguir dejan los comentarios y las
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
y no olviden también nos pueden escuchar
a través de nuestros podcast sigan con
france24
[Música]